hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 2004 wreck avec rapid between
Garry Kasparov who's playing the white
pieces vs. Magnus Carlsen at the time
Kasparov was rated 28:31 in Carlsen
still just a 13 year old international
master was rated 2484 this game lasted
32 moves but I think it's a pretty good
one to go through because it involves
arguably one of the best ever chess
players Garry Kasparov II and the number
one chess player as of the July 2011
feat a rating list Magnus Carlsen one
other interesting thing to note is that
about one month after this game was
played that's when Magnus Carlsen met
all the requirements for that
Grandmaster title so let's have a look
at this we have Kasparov opening up with
c-4 Carlsen Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 going
for the Kings Indian set up and now e4
putting a giant grip on that d5 square
so there is not going to be any d5 move
if d5 did want to get played it's gonna
have to be played right now but we don't
have that g6e for d6 d4 so with such a
pawn Center black is certainly gonna
have to strike at it at some point and
since d5 is no longer on the cards we're
going to need either the C pawn or epon
to strike at the white pawn center so
Bishop g7 Knight f3 Castle Bishop e2 and
now e5 so black is going with this pawn
striking in the center and now Bishop to
e3 there is no win of a pond because
even though this Knight wins the pawn in
this position it's also unprotected and
it fails well it could just be met with
just Knight takes pawn discovered attack
on the knight so instead we just have
more development by white Bishop e3
developing the bishop watching over d4
and now black gives up the center
capturing on d4 instead we could see
knight Knight g4 attacking the bishop
chasing it to g5 just showing a few
moves deep and that's as far as I want
to take this right here f6 the bishop is
hit and it has a big decision to make
where exactly does it want to reside the
knight on the other hand is either going
to be kicked away to h6 or it will
voluntarily go to that h6 Square where
it will then pivot on F cell
and be a pretty good contributor to this
be 5 square which is a strong point for
the black position we don't enter that
territory instead again black gives up
the center after pawn takes how exactly
to recapture capturing that the Queen
would allow Knight G for both Queen and
Bishop being hit something you want to
avoid
similarly Bishop takes would allow a
knight development with tempo so that's
why we have Knight takes and now c6 an
important point is this position right
here because it may be very very
tempting to just want to let's say
castle and even though this is a
developing move at may certain it could
run into some trouble here because after
rook e8 how exactly to meet the pressure
against that eforp on do you move that
Bishop again do you move this Queen to
let's say C 2 let's take a look at the
Queen C to move first and foremost do
this does this Queen really want to play
the role of watching over a pond
probably not and that move could be met
with let's say just Knight g4 chase
trying to chase that Bishop away from
the defense of the night white would
pretty much be forced into giving up the
bishop pair when there's position here
which is still open I don't know if that
could really be recommended also if you
do f3 well that's not going to allow a
move like d5 taking advantage of the
fact that this bishop is now unprotected
and so y could capture in this direction
with that pawn but when it comes to this
pond it's pretty much powerless can't
capture because of rook takes Bishop so
how to really maybe deal with this
situation
white or black makes this c6 move in
order to prepare d5 and so instead of
castle in other words in this position
we have white playing f3 taking this
move into account preparing to me this
rook to e8 move which is played with now
not castle
but Bishop f2 what does this move doing
it's getting out of harm's way along
this efile and it's allowing this pond
to have more strength it has its
strength back and so this next move
Bible
back d5 can now be met with he takes D
and that's exactly what we see so he
takes D C takes D and now C 5 so a great
change has just occurred with regard to
the pawn structure we have a
three-on-two with regard to the
queenside structure city and we also
have an isolated pawn on d5 what that
implies is that d4 is going to be an
important Square for white to maintain
control over and the reason for that is
because if you don't have control over
it
this pond could push forward and this is
a past pun and you're gonna want to keep
it
blockaded at its very earliest point and
d4 is that point the other thing to take
note of is that since this pawn is now
on the c5 square you'll note that its
support points are going to be important
for black to be taking into account so
what are this pawns support points its
support points are both b6 and d6 b6
really isn't too much of a concern it's
not like there's gonna be some some
knight landing on the b6 square because
we have the a 7-pound watching over it
but you'll note that the other square
this d6 square is very vulnerable to the
black side right here it's a hole in the
black position and it has that c5 pawn
which acts as a supporter for that a
knight let's say getting to that square
so certainly a square to be cautious of
is that d6 square but before we even get
there we have more development for black
knight c6 only now does white castle and
now Knight to h5 looking to pivot on f4
but white is able to conveniently defend
that quote with the Queen to d2 and I
use the word convenient because I think
that Queen might have wanted to go there
anyway and now she's doing a couple
things in fact she's watching over f2
she's stopping the knife from pivoting
there and she's also vacating this d1
square for the Queen rook after Bishop
e5 well what does that move looking to
do it's it's lending support to that f4
square so this move is maybe available
but white just stops that with g3 and
even though weakens the h3 square this
really isn't that much that big of a
problem really for the white side the
piece is for the black side if they
can't really crash through they're just
gonna start to become a little bit
misplaced this guy right here in
particular one other thing to know is
that at the very early stage in the game
in by very early I'm referring to move
to when black makes this move g6 they're
kind of saying that one of their minor
pieces is going to hold a greater value
than any other minor pieces that they
have that piece being their dark square
bishop and the reason for that is
because what does g6 do exactly well it
prepares for that Bishop to be developed
to g7 but it's also weakening f6 and h6
and so if you're going to on the black
side give up your dark square Bishop in
some in some manner and still if there
are still let's say a lot of pieces
remaining on the board in particular the
Queen's that could certainly turn out to
be a problem and in this game it's a big
problem
so after Bishop to e5 we have g3 h3 is
weakened black tries to take advantage
of that you know the bishop is deep in
the white position controlling squares
near the white King but you'll know that
even though the rook is attacked it's
maybe just being chased away to a square
it already wanted to go to certainly
this file is going to be a good one for
white rook so we have rook e1 after 97
this is where it starts to maybe show
itself a little bit that the
coordination of the black pieces is just
a little bit off when we have I guess
you'd say a fiing keto tonight not
really the ideal placement for a knight
the other pieces are maybe well-placed
but this night right here on g7 not so
hot and usually it'll just take one
poorly placed piece in order for your
position to may be crumble and the
position really does crumble very very
fast unfortunately for black before we
have any really strong move just yet we
do have rook on a 2 d1 getting the last
piece involved
bolstering the center right here these
these rooks very very well-placed hard
to suggest better placements for those
rooks the knight on c3 classically
developed it's it's very well on that on
that square the bishops there it's a
really really nice setup for white but
again what's really glaring for the
black side unfortunately is that night
on g7 so routed your rook to c8 trying
to get some other piece involved but I
think it's just too little too late at
this point unfortunately because of the
idea the really simple idea of getting a
knight to that d6 square and it starts
with Knight on D to b5 and I don't know
that there's really much that black can
do in this position what black ended up
choosing to do was kick the knight to
that square and so after Bishop takes
Knight because we do have this fork
going on so that knight move comes with
that much more of an effect not only is
it just pivoting on a hole but it's
hitting both rooks so Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes Bishop and now d4 this
right here is a pretty interesting
position it may be very tempting to just
want to go ahead and grab that pawn but
white doesn't they play 94 trying to
just focus on f6 and that's very telling
in this game but before we get to that
point if instead we did have Bishop
takes pawn there's an interesting
variation that I took note of in this
game and it may may have come in the
following form if Knight captures Bishop
in this position Queen captures Knight
f5 could start to maybe cause white some
problems and I think black could maybe
wriggle wriggle out of this situation
even though this pawn is very deep and
looking to press forward to d7 2 for
both rooks what exactly to do in this
position if let's say the Queen maybe
retreats to d2 you know we could have
now Queen to b6 and this is an
interesting variation that I ended up
finding after this check King h1 night -
e3 this could be really problematic for
white
well problematic to the point where
white could maybe get away with a draw
at this point the rook is being hit and
if white was maybe banking on this
particular move working it actually
doesn't for example if d7 in this
position we could have Bishop g2 check
King g1 Knight takes rook discover check
King takes Bishop Queen f2 check King h1
and after Knight takes Knight it seems
like white is still gonna be quite
alright and they're gonna be up a piece
after the smoke has cleared but not so
fast actually
because after pawn takes Knight we now
have rook on C to D a and after pawn
takes rook rook takes Queen in this
Queens position is great
she can't be dislodged she's keeping the
King right in the corner we have a
five-on-five with regard to the pawns
and a situation here where this Bishop
is caught in a crossfire pinned in both
directions and the Queen with its
pressure on the rook there's nothing
that this Bishop can do even though it's
present on the board it's kind of in a
position where it just can't move
anywhere and so there's no progress to
be made unfortunately in this position
and just showing let's say one quick
draw in this position it would come in
the following form black could always
just make it move like h5 and then move
the King back and forth on let's say g8
and h7 and there's no progress to be
made on the white side and that's it's
just it would just turn out to be a
drama so I don't know that this would
all be forced I think it is maybe forced
at this point right here if we did have
Queen to d2 but maybe there is something
maybe a little bit different but I
thought that that was one interesting
variation which maybe white had spotted
and just wanted to avoid altogether at
this point right here so instead of in
other words capturing on d4 we had
Knight to e4 focusing instead on a
preserving this bishop and by doing so
you're preventing any nonsense that
might occur against your King along this
diagonal
and be keeping it again a close eye on
that f6 square so Bishop f5
unfortunately is met with a really nice
move and that is d7 landing a4 chat
these two rooks and if Queen takes this
is gonna be lights out very quick
so instead Bishop takes is necessary and
only now at this point do we have Bishop
takes on e4
because after Knight takes bishop you
know that is the move that gets played
but you'll note that getting that Knight
to that f6 square is going to be very
troublesome to the black side after
Knight takes Bishop Queen takes Knight
once again this Knight is getting ready
to pivot on f6 again black does not have
a dark squared Bishop f6 h6 if you can
maybe access either those squares look
to do that in your own games certainly
f6 is going to be the one white is
looking to get to from such a position
here there is no there is no way out
unfortunately for black at this point
it's just downhill there is no way to
save the game so how this actually
finishes up is Knight to f5 there's
nothing really else to do this Bishop is
hit twice the knight is getting ready to
go to f6 after Knight to f5 the Queen is
being attacked white of course just has
to be maybe a little bit careful here
not to just go forward with Knight to f6
check King h8 and this Queen is being
hit and she can't move to a square where
she still keeps a close eye on f6 and so
if the Queen now takes on d7 we would
have Queen takes Knight in black is
getting out of any trouble so instead we
just have of course not just the knight
going to f6 but just queen takes bishop
and this game finishes up very quickly
Queen gives check King goes to the
corner there's just a little bit of
pressure that black is able to play
sunlight but after white is consolidates
that's gonna be very telling white is
certainly up a piece at this point Queen
takes pawn white is up material so you
offer Queen exchanges what else is there
really to do after the exchange of
Queens Bishop c4
94 hitting on f3 but after rook to e3 to
defend that pond since white has now
consolidated and there's no more
pressure that black in place on white
black ends up resigning at this point so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye